here's the story my friends and let the
censorship begin in I think it was 2018
they went after Alex Jones they went
after who else have they been Laura
Loomer milianopolis uh who else got
caught up in that it was a big wave of
people that got uh Sargon he got it
early I think I don't think he was part
of that wave Paul Joseph Watson I think
they went after him they got rid of his
Instagram and it was a bunch of just
pictures of him like smoking a cigarette
with the Sun a sunset behind him it's
like that was just gotta go he got rid
of him well here's the story Glenn
Beck's show removed from Apple podcast
the tech giant gave the podcaster no
warning prior to his Show's removal
scary stuff he put out this uh video
saying what's the issue and a video
shared 2x the podcaster said the email
from Apple's podcast team contained a
link though the link brought him to
another page informing him his podcast
has been removed from the platform we
found an issue with your show The Glenn
Beck program which must be resolved
before it's available on Apple podcasts
he said I cannot imagine what they're
basing this on the podcaster said
Apple's removal of the Glenn black
program was crazy and encouraged people
to share his post and demand Apple
podcasts to reinstate the show
if this was not Glenn Beck if it was any
other podcast they would not be restored
it's only because it's a high profile
personality in political commentary I
bet Apple nukes tons of shows all the
time and their smaller shows that maybe
you'll get only a few thousand downloads
per episode no one knows it's happening
Glenn Beck said looks like apple
restored my 3 000 plus episodes to their
platform but still don't have clear
answers as to why this happened hope to
have an update for you tomorrow on radio
I want to thank everyone on the left
right and everyone in between who spoke
up today I wish I had better answers
from Apple on what happened but you gave
me hope that the issue of censorship is
still bigger than politics there were a
lot of people uh on the left who were
saying okay look man like you know you
might not like Glenn Beck but that's
kind of crazy they nuked his show it's
weird that it seems like they've got
like a kill switch for essentially
entire channels I mean well I mean maybe
it makes sense there Rogue employee like
with uh when Donald Trump got banned
from Twitter remember that yeah but
there's even still it's like if there if
there is a rogue employee that's
actually doing the you know shut it off
or whatever it seems like it's something
that's fairly simple for someone to do
as in it doesn't take there's not a lot
of backups there's no doesn't seem like
there's checks in any kind of checks or
anything whatever you know I would think
that it would be like the either one of
the lead developers or like some one of
the one of the owners of the spot was it
Spotify Apple music is that music so
it's like usually most employees don't
have access to shutting off channels
completely unless you're like a really
well-trusted respected administrator but
even then that would be a big risk for
the company to give an administrator
that kind of ability so I'm thinking
like someone up in the in the
development chain Musta which means that
it went through a series of calls like
it wasn't just someone just decided to
do it that someone would have told
someone to do it and then they went
ahead and pushed it and then they
temporarily made it invisible to Glenn
he thought it was deleted but they just
had a invis mode until they could
resolve something I don't know this
happens a lot and um I wonder if this is
a shot across the bow for conservative
commentary and and Glenn Beck being a
conservative commentator but also
obviously anybody who is supporting
Trump in any way pushing back on the
narrative machine I saw this clip Vivek
ramaswamy was talking to Neil Cavuto and
Cavuto is like Donald Trump's now been
indicted you know 90 some odd counts and
Vivek was like clearly it's political
and Cavuto goes you don't think even one
of them I mean certainly and and is like
no Cavuto argues why Trump actually is
guilty because there's so many charges
the fake makes an excellent point saying
we cannot become a country that simply
says because there are so many charges
one of them must be true no you're
innocent until proven guilty but that
shows you where Fox News is at obviously
Fox news is anti-trump pro-establishment
they get rid of Tucker Carlson we know
what's going on now they're arguing that
Trump must be guilty in some way
then they go after people like Glenn
Beck they're going to try and take down
Independent Media we've already got
people in the super chat before the show
started saying they can't find this show
well yeah this happens all the time it
should appear on the front page of your
YouTube channel of YouTube when you go
there if you're subscribed a lot of
people are like I can't find it we've
actually had people say they go to the
YouTube channel for timcast IRL and
there's no live stream it's just not
there not visible for them even though
we're live with you know 30 plus
thousand people watching
if you go to youtube.com live typically
every night we are the number one live
show but people still have a hard time
to find that's one way you can find it
we're gonna get in 2024 and you better
believe it they're going to get rid of
anybody here's what I think if you're
pro-desantis you'll probably be okay
if you are pro-trump you will probably
be hidden I think people if they want to
watch the show can go to timcast.com
every night at 8pm and then you can you
can link to it from the from the
website's front page so start going if
you're having trouble if you ever think
you have trouble you don't want to ever
have trouble go to timcast.com at eight
o'clock Eastern it's right there in the
homepage you can link it through to the
YouTube if you want to watch it from
YouTube or you can just watch it on the
website I think though to the Apple
Point specifically conservatives have
this kind of consensus of thinking that
you know corporations are Untouchable
because we all worship at the altar of
the free market right but what we're
seeing is that these corporations are
taking our freedoms they're acting as
tyrants so I think we we need to get a
lot more comfortable on the right with
you know trust busting certain
corporations or really enforcing certain
laws and just ensuring that they are
protecting the Liberties that the
Constitution and Trust to every single
American it's a bigger issue of the
Republicans they don't do anything yeah
no they write strongly worded letters
that's right that's what our party does
I mean just really good at it yeah no we
are I mean in the wake of the Fulton
County indictment all we're doing is
tweeting we see you know Kevin McCarthy
and various GOP leader just putting out
statements and fiery tweets there's zero
action and I think the base wants action
the American people see this stuff
they're enraged they're infuriated they
want retribution that's why they love
Donald Trump but I think they're
frustrated with the kind of
establishment Washington D.C cartel
that's just doing nothing what kind of
action could people take like legal you
know righteous action because I'm
racking my brain what could people do in
terms of Corporations I mean there's a
lot that you can do like these
corporations are too massive number one
um they collude with the government
there needs to be a lot more barriers
there that kind of we saw with the
Twitter files right that the government
was actually asking Twitter to do things
and then they were you know complying in
a sense so we need to be sure that that
there are Protections in place so that
that kind of collusion can't happen
so like
so like make them hmm that's yeah what
would that look like though like uh like
putting it making them do it in public I
mean there's always can't force people
to talk in public yeah I mean I think
there needs to be a period of a lot of
transparency and we're seeing a little
bit of that with the weaponization
committee that's happening in Congress
right now we're seeing some of these
files start to come out and we're
getting evidence
um so I think we need more of that I
think we need to kind of uncover what's
been done and then we can kind of go
after these corporations and make sure
you know that they are serving the
interests of the American people when
our Founders conceptualize what a
corporation would be it was kind of akin
to a British Charter it had to serve the
common good it had to be publicly
beneficial to the people that lived in
that country and I think now if you look
at most modern corporations I mean they
act as tyrants They don't serve the
American people at all when did that
happen it was like 1850s when did the
modern Corporation take over it was uh
let's see the first American corporation
was organized in 1894 as Orange County
Title Company company succeeding the two
businesses uh the the business of two
title abstract companies founded in 1889
and operating in Orange County
California is that that's like right
before Rockefeller like got a
Stranglehold on standard oil on the
country with through Standard Oil and
then they eventually broke up Standard
Oil turned it into like six six other
oil companies the Rockefeller still a
piece of so it didn't really so now you
have multinational corporations too like
you have corporations that are working
at the behest of the globally not even
just you know american-centric or
focused they're caring about you know
what Klaus Schwab wants and you can't so
for the American government to go to
like BlackRock and tell it to do
something blackrock's like well where's
their headquarters is it even in the US
right now I'm not sure is it in
Switzerland or whatever but they don't
have to because they're not American but
then so we could be like you can't
operate here unless you play by our
rules which as long as we're a strong
robust economy and a force that's that's
has bargaining power but if if people
don't take the US seriously and we tell
Google like hey unless you free your
software code you can't function in the
United States they might just shut down
the United States so it's like and we
could do shows of force like that like
we could tell Apple hey like no or
Amazon you know no more Manufacturing in
China and if they do we seize their boat
when it arrives at a port in California
oh I'd love to see if at any point it
was possible Republicans actually exert
some kind of power they just don't well
yeah that's that that's I honestly I
think that that's asking more than than
is reasonable to expect and what would
you get from Libertarians they would be
even worse with exerting power they'd be
like no it's against our ethos you'd get
a Dave Smith X space at eight o'clock
P.M Eastern right while we're doing our
show today yeah they're doing a live
space you Libertarians ah no I'm just
kidding but like if Libertarians got
elected they'd be like oh oh drat
they're they're doing awful things again
what could they do exactly like well
firstly why do you think that there's
such inactivity on the side of both
political parties and secondly what golf
yeah no they just indicted Trump's
lawyers
are playing Hardball
the reason why there's demonic
activities on the side of Democrats is
because they're evil power hungry
Psychopaths and the reason why there's
inaction on the part of the Republicans
is because they're actually Democrats
who are power hungry Psychopaths but
they're only Wham Republican masks so
the uniparty bought out by the
corporations and they're just floating
you know while we're all down on under
the deck trying to put the fire out
there's a handful of Republicans who are
legitimate some of them are more
libertarian leaning some of them are
Maga or anti-establishment but what
there's like 20 of them yeah the other
option is Boycott you know that's only
what boycott Apple but the boycotts are
working yeah Disney Disney's Shares are
are are at risk because of news
reporting about there's another boycott
happening and they're starting to freak
out Target lost for the first time in
six years massive amounts of money and
their stock dropped by like 27 but light
is on the verge is collapsing that's
that's fair enough but Apple there was
one point in the in the past couple
years where Apple had more actual cash
than the federal government that's wild
like that's that was a real thing so
whereas yes I I get like boycotts can
can move the needle and stuff uh I'm not
sure apple is who yeah I don't want to
be able to because Apple said that is
more of a global company too they're
they're selling iPhones all over the you
know the whole world so I mean and hey
I'm I'm I'm only telling you my
impression it's I was wrong about the
Bud Light uh boycott in the first place
I didn't think it was a good idea and
apparently I was wrong about that so
fair enough but I think Apple's a bit of
a different company company so yeah I'm
not it's not not too concerned with
Apple only because Glenn Beck they shut
they got rid of his podcast did that is
the one that came out of my mouth but
any kind of multinational company or
American company that's actually de
facto multinational that's betraying our
interests we could boycott or at least
attempt to
um you know but then like you know if
these companies get you integrated in
our society and you try and boycott them
like I want to boycott Microsoft are you
kidding me like all my computers are
running Windows right now I don't know
you can get Ubuntu and use wine I've
tried that but I can't game it's not
good yeah for those that are familiar
wine is a way to run Windows programs on
Linux it's just not good yeah but I love
Ubuntu and it is really is awesome that
that people have built this like open
source and a lot of free software on the
platform it's cool it's cool that it
exists only thing I know about Ubuntu is
that's what I used when I was mining
ethereum well I'll tell you about it is
it makes tons of money for massive
multinational corporations because when
they need to operate like point of sale
terminals or self-checkouts why pay pay
for a license for Windows on your as
your operating system when Linux is free
so a bunch of them they use legs a bunch
of servers use Linux because they're
like free software there you go thanks
for watching this clip from the timcast
IRL podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8 pm and become a
member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time